aujourd'hui nous reprenons l'étude
articles par article du projet de loi
C13 la fracture dans le caucus libéral
est évidente je laisse la parole à
Monsieur houseford des députés de
l'ouest de Montréal s'attaquent au
projet de loi C13 soit la modernisation
de la Loi sur les langues officielles
puisqu'il évoque la Charte québécoise de
la langue française fédéralement on
devrait avoir l'accès à des services
dans les deux langues tu pars tout dans
le pays c'est pas ça dans la Charte la
langue française aujourd'hui c'est pas
ça dans la loi 96 Anthony hausseforter
Marc Garnaud et Emmanuel allambre poulos
tenté de faire modifier le texte
législatif un effort dénoncé par le
Franco-Ontarien Francis Drouin qui écrit
le shoot boucan mené par certains de mes
collègues et honteux le Montréal Island
n'a pas le monopole sur la politique
linguistique du Canada si quelqu'un soit
cocu ce qu'il sort sur le président ce
sont des mots justes comment ça se fait
que ça prend un autre à rien pour
publier ça accusé par l'opposition de
perdre le contrôle de ses troupes juste
un Trudeau répète que les libéraux vont
respecter leur engagement on a toujours
mis de l'avant une reconnaissance que
non seulement on doit protéger les deux
langues officielles à travers le pays on
doit particulièrement protéger le
français et particulièrement et même au
Québec oui aujourd'hui c'est une journée
historique le projet de loi C13 présenté
par la ministre des langues officielles
le printemps dernier vise à mieux
protéger la place du français au Canada
mais des libéraux veulent défendre la
minorité anglophone du Québec dont celle
de la circonscription montréalaise de
Notre-Dame de grâce-houest je trouve que
le gouvernement Québec ils font assez
pour protéger la langue française
mais l'essentiel c'est la protection du
français c'est la défense du français
tout le monde devrait en faire davantage
pour plus le fédéral que le provincial
mais
je trouve que le français est bien mal
protégé actuellement protéger le
français oui mais comment l'approche à
adopter à cause des divisions la
modernisation de la Loi sur les langues
officielles attendues depuis longtemps
s'avère plus tard du prévu ici Sébastien
Desrosiers Radio-Canada Montréal